I think we need to make it clear that
all the ceasefires that have been
announced haven't held through on the
ground airstrikes have continued during
all the ceasefires we've seen including
on ground fighting but and that has
meant that even through all those
ceasefires people have continued to come
here to see to seek safety Point Sudan
is a sleepy Port Town it's a historic
port and it's seen thousands of people
coming from all around the world and
there's not enough space to accommodate
them but people have been open up
opening up their homes hotels have been
cutting down their rates there's been an
understanding that this is life or death
that people are coming here trying to
find safety now people again all over
the world there are syrians who fled the
war in Syria and have told me they've
come and found War here again it's a
desperate situation and this morning our
Turkish military plane leaving where
they see now the same military base used
to evacuate Brits was was shot in the
sky thankfully no one was injured no one
was hurt but that has is that military
base for evacuations and it has to be
said there have been many complaints
about how unsafe That Base was because
there are many checkpoints there was
lots of fighting around there were
complaints to the foreign office
complete to the British Embassy from
British citizens in Sudan who felt like
they couldn't evacuate safety safely and
now they're playing being shot down
proved that point so what's happened is
that everyone will be coming here
they've been advised informally that
this is the safest place to be evacuated
from we've seen Saudi evacuations we've
seen three Saudi military vessels
transport of 2 500 people from all over
the world from here there have been
other evacuations there's this by plane
from the base but there's also a sense
that this is the place to be if you want
to leave the country now just behind me
there are people who are sleeping just
rough they've come they've escaped War
they've had to leave their homes and now
they're sleeping on the ground there's a
sense of trash you know they're
transitioning but they don't know if if
they'll make it through and just behind
there's the broadcasting house and as we
came in they were announcing passport
numbers and names telling people to
register for the evacuations that are
coming there's a Saudi evacuation boat
arriving tomorrow here and people are
signing up to get on we've seen we've
seen desks registering yemeni yemeni
citizens being told that they will get
on the Saudi evacuation ship so people
are not
they've come and they're urgently trying
to find ways out they're not resting on
their loyal Laurels they're not relying
on embassies they're trying to get out
through any means possible and it's just
what you feel here is there is a sense
of relief this is a very calm warm
welcoming City but there's just also
this shock that things turned so quickly
in a country that they call home people
have been living here for for decades
and also needs people here we're trying
to find their way out who also find it
extremely difficult to sign up for the
Saudi evacuation ship because of the
fact that they need to have a foreign
passport or residency in Saudi Arabia
it's also important to note that we came
in this morning on a commercial ferry
from Jeddah that had Sudanese people
actually coming back
it's just insane coming back to their
country because they love it so much
even during times of War people want to
be here because their families are here
we met a man who's who's whose mother
and daughter were killed trying to flee
on a road by the car a car accident
because there was just such a frenzy of
people leaving initially to come here
and now that frenzy is going to continue
these are Road Journeys by Road by car
anything can happen and the city doesn't
seem Corazon doesn't seem to be getting
any safer for the people that live there
we met a humanitarian worker yesterday
who just come in on the evacuation
vessel and he said that we are going as
time goes on we are going to realize
just how shocking the humanitarian
condition is in Sudan the fact that
there are people still trapped in their
homes with no electricity no water but
also no signal on their phones unable to
communicate not only with people
internally to get help but also their
loved ones across the world who have
just been waiting it's been two weeks
that this war has been ongoing and
mediation after threats seem to not work
you know the two generals
the head of the rsf the head of the army
they're refusing to meet at the
negotiation table there's been extensive
efforts from igad from their property
from the president of Kenya from the
president of South Sudan offering to
mediate offering to to come into the
country and liaise and we spoke to the
Army Chief early on in the conflict and
he said the situation was too unsafe to
accommodate them though he's open to
negotiations as time went on it was very
clear that the Army Chief was not open
to negotiations because the airstrikes
again continued during a ceasefire
hundreds of people have been killed
thousands injured and more than anything
so many have had to leave their homes to
find safety abroad and the initiatives
that are happening as much as the Saudi
evacuations are helping their thousands
more that need help thousands more that
need safety and and still many people
subtracting who are trying to find their
way out we will see over the next period
this place not just be continues but
also a camp a makeshift camp for people
who may never get to leave who don't
have the passports that allow them to
get on International evacuation flights
who don't have the money to find another
way and so the crisis is continuing and
there's no there's no sign of whether
peace will actually holding